famously played dr cox on scrubs for
nine years brilliantly and i'm just cute
thank you i'm told
i can't believe it that was a hard part
for you to get
when i went in to audition for uh scrubs
the in the margin of the script it said
we're looking for a john mcginley type
and so i read it and i said well this is
a stone cold lock yeah so i went in to
audition for bill lawrence the creative
scrubs and ground floor which is what
we're on now and i said uh hi bill
i'm i'm john mcginley i'm i'm the type
and he said well great but uh you're
still gonna have to audition five times
so i'll be damned if i didn't audition
for that thing five times climbing the
network ladder of of different people
who get a say in the casting process and
i finally got it and they they got their
john mcginley type
written for you come on it's like when i
auditioned for the show conan uh we're
looking for a conan type you're not
quite what we're looking for
tell us about ground floor are you
enjoying being on tbs uh i got ground
floor right after yes i'm enjoying being
on tvs and i got ground floor right
after i'd done glengarry glenn gross on
broadway with al pacino and bobby
cannavale and richard schiff and all
these great actors and so i was in good
live theater fighting shape yes and bill
lawrence who did uh uh scrubs said do
you want to do a live four camera show
here at warner brothers on stage 19 and
i said uh yeah
because it's like doing an off-broadway
play every tuesday night when we shoot
it and so it's been thrilling there's
this young group of actors on it from
from skyler to to brieger and rory who
you know on their show and so it's
thrilling the show's on tuesday nights
at 10 o'clock and it's the most fun
thing i've ever done there and you can
tell too there's a great energy that
comes off of all of you working together
absolutely i i one thing that impresses
me is there's a little tiny bit of
memorization that comes with doing a
show every day but i'm constantly we're
working off each other they'll hold up a
card there'll be ways that we can cheat
you're kind of
got a very good reputation in the
business for being able to memorize
incredible runs on scrubs i was always
amazed at those long speeches you could
give with lightning speed what's your
what's your story two things well i
write it i write it out in a composition
book uh and then i wrote i put verbs in
the margin of what i'm trying to do and
then i juggle and if i juggle while i'm
doing the lines and i drop a ball it
means either i don't know the lines or
the lines aren't right for me and so
it's like an x-ray machine for dialogue
memorization and so i've just come up
with that system over the years you can
do that you can juggle and and recite
something from memory at the same time
kim i could do a poem for you right now
you do a poem for us sure sure yeah
we said you might do this we have
i keep baseballs here at all time i
never know what's going to happen and uh
what
what poem are you gonna
what paul are you gonna do for us el
dorado by edgar allan poe edgar allan
poes
el dorado while juggling
do you have any mood lighting we can't
afford that hope
uh yeah uh do something with the lights
here we go
ready andy i'm ready
gaily bedey to gallant knight in
sunshine and in shadow had journeyed
long singing a song in search of
eldorado but he grew old this night so
bold and or as hard as shadow fell as he
found no spot of ground that looked
like el dorado
[Applause]
[Music]
that was fantastic